et avec nous pour ce club Alain Cadec
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sénateur les républicains des côes
d'Armor vous êtes ancien député européen
vice-président de la commission des
affaires européennes au Sénat Michael
Weber bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous vous êtes-vous sénateur socialiste
de la Moselle on va parler de la crise
agricole mais aussi de la colère des
pêcheurs privés de pêche pendant plus
d'un mois sur tout le littoral
atlantique agriculteurs pêcheurs notre
souverineté alimentaire est-elle en
danger et les réponses du Premier
ministre sont-elles suffisantes vous
nous direz ce que vous en pensez Marion
on va également parler de l'un des point
qui a suscité la colère des agriculteurs
c'est l'excès de norme exactement et
nous évoquerons les mesures de
simplification qui ont été proposées par
le gouvernement de Gabriel Atal ça sera
suivre dans quelques instants c'est tout
de suite ce club on va pas on va voir ce
qui se passe du côté de la Vendé
[Musique]
notamment et depuis le 11 janvier
jusqu'au 20 février les bateaux de plus
d' m sont donc un interdit de pêche dans
le golfe de Gascogne une zone qui
s'étend de la frontière espagnole au
finisterère la raison une décision du
Conseil d'État pour protéger les
dauphins décision qui provoque la colère
et l'inquiétude des pêcheurs Jérôme
Rabier s'est rendu sur place au sable
d'Olonne en
vendet comme 500 autres propriétaires de
bateau de pêche de la façade ouest
Adrien de laavau est à qu depuis
maintenant 2 semaines en cause une
décision du Conseil d'État qui interdit
pour un mois la pêche dans le golfe de
Gascogne pour préserver les dauphins
pour lui comme pour son équipage une
perte énorme dans son meilleur mois de
l'année la vision c'est 30 à 40 % de mon
chiffre d'affaires annuel donc on sait
déjà que même en reprenant même si ça
pêche bien on sait déjà que l'année a
perdu 30 à 40 % on va dire 30 % quoi
stopper les entreprise c'est bien mais
faut quand même que les ouvriers comme
moi le patron on a du matériel à à payer
les ouvriers des des maisons des enfants
des écoles à payer donc aujourd'hui il y
a quand même une grosse part
de doute quoi pour lui qui s'est équipé
pour éviter la prise accidentelle de
dauphin la sanction est injuste et même
si le gouvernement promet de compenser
85 % des pertes c'est l'incompréhension
qui domine faut pas oublier qu'on fait
partie de la souveraineté alimentaire
donc comme les agriculteurs on subit on
subit des obligations de de
réglementation des choses comme ça plus
aujourd'hui des arrêts de de travail on
nous demande aujourd'hui de on a un
Premier ministre qui fait les annonces
du travail du travail bah nous on nous
interdit de travailler donc je je
comprends pas trop quoi le le discours
alors que les agriculteurs ont obtenu
des avancées après leur blocage Adrien
del laavau estime que la pêche subit les
mêmes contraintes et surtout un manque
de visibilité c'est c'est tous les ans
comme ça c'est un combat perpétuel tous
les ans c'est la hausse du prix du
gasoil c'est les quotas c'est les
interdictions c'est les obligations les
revalidations d'examen c'est une
pression constante quoi
et on nous demande après c'est on va
vous aider on vous indemnise pourcentage
nous on veut pas d'argent on va juste
travailler conséquence de l'interdiction
c'est toute la filière qui est impactée
les Cais sont vides les marilleeurs
n'ont plus de marchandise et les
poissonniers doivent s'approvisionner
ailleurs pour les représentants des
pêcheurs il faut une prise de conscience
au sommet ce qu'on attend oui c'est que
le Président de la République continue à
ce qu'il semble avoir commencé faire
pour les agriculteurs dire on est dans
l'Europe on entend par contre il y a des
particularismes et la pêche fait partie
comme n'importe quel autre secteur
d'activité d' de l'histoire française
tout simplement quoi ce jourl au sable
deolonne le comité des pêch reçoit la
visite de François Xavier béami tête de
liste les républicains aux européennes
au côté du sénateur deand et Bruno
rotillot après un temps d'échang avec
les pêcheurs il demande que les
propositions de la droite soi entendu il
faut que la pêche connu comme une
filière stratégique dans la loi
française c'est la proposition que les
républicains portaient depuis des années
notamment pour l'agriculture le Premier
ministre a repris notre proposition pour
l'agriculture il faut qu'on intègre la
pêche la pêche est une activité
stratégique les pêcheurs pourront
retrouver la mer à partir du 21 février
mais cette interdiction pourrait se
répéter en 2025 et 2026 les pêcheurs
demandent donc des aménagements pour
éviter d'être bloqués au port au plus de
leur activité annuelle Alain cadek vous
avez entendu la colère le désarroi
l'inquiétude de ce pêcheur comment on y
répond d'abord je partage cette cette
colère cette inquiétude de ce pêcheur
parce qu'aujourd'hui la pêche européenne
en général la pêche française en
particulier est quasiment en danger déjà
les conséquences du brexit sont
dramatiques puisque on a eu un plan de
sortie de flotte extrêmement important
ce qui a diminué de manière très
importante notre capacité ce qu'on
appelle notre capacité c'est-à-dire
notre production ça veut dire que euh
dans une période où on nous dit euh il
faut tendre vers la souveraineté
alimentaire et on on on diminue notre
propre production aujourd'hui en France
faut savoir quand même qu'on importe
grosso modo 70 à 75 % des produit de de
de la mer qu'on consomme vous vous
rendez compte un pays comme la France
pourquoi parce que parce qu'on est au
sein de l'Europe que la politique de la
pêche est une politique totalement
intégrée et heureusement d'ailleurs il y
a ce qu'on appelle la PCP la politique
commune de la pêche qui permet de de de
de mettre des règles euh et qui
permettent de préserver euh la ressource
alors quand en plus euh arrive comme le
disait José junau tout de suite
président du comité régional euh des
pêche quant AR cette une décision comme
ça unilatérale du Conseil d'État je
rappelle puisque le le gouvernement
avait retiré euh de de stopper
totalement euh l'activité de la pêche
dans un secteur alors le prétexte est
est est tout à fait acceptable il faut
euh préserver évidemment il faut
préserver sassé et les dauphins en
particulier mais pas seulement euh bien
entendu ça on est tous d'accord
là-dessus mais les pêcheurs font déjà
des très gros efforts ils mettent ce
qu'on appelle des dispositifs
d'éloignement sur leur sur leur filet
les les les pélagiques les chit
pélagiques font très attention aux
endroits où ils passent donc je pense
que là c'est une décision beaucoup trop
beaucoup trop du pour les pêcheurs parce
que il y a eu 2500 captures
accidentelles l'année dernière est-ce
que quand même à un
momentcis evidemment j'ai pris quelques
renseignements auprès d' fr il y a de
plus en plus de C asset dans le golf de
Gascogne donc mécaniquement il y aura de
plus en plus malheureusement de de de de
de prise donc il faut aussi relativiser
tout ça donc alors du coup comment on
aide les pêcheurs parce que le
gouvernement
c'est c'est ça suffit pas par que
Christophe Béchu il s'est exprimer lors
des questions d'actualité mardi à
l'Assemblée il a dit 20 février
ouverture des guichets d'aide aux
pêcheurs pour que les paiements puissent
arriver au mois de mars c'est pas la
bonne réponse ça fait 7 ans qu'on donne
de l'argent à tout le monde on donne de
l'argent qu'on n pas d'ailleurs entre
parenthèses 3200 milliards de dette au
pays donc c'est c'est pas une solution
et c'est pas ce que demandent les
pêcheurs les pêcheurs ils demandent
comme les agriculteurs d'ailleurs de
pouvoir vivre de leur métier donc c'est
pas en leur donnant 80 % des revenus
qu'ils ont eu l'année dernière que ça va
changer quelque chose par ailleurs on
voit bien que le le discours de de de
Christophe Béchu comme le discours du
gouvernement général et du Premier
ministre Gabriel Atal en particulier
c'est toujours le même c'est-à-dire
qu'on on donne on va compenser on va
donner de l'argent en attendant
l'électricité augmente quand même hein
de plus de 10 % donc voyez euh double
l'engage le en même temps quoi Michel
Weber c'est pas la bonne réponse
qu'apporte le gouvernement d'aider les
pêcheurs face à cette perte énorme dans
un mois qui est très important moi moi
je dis pas que c'est il faut le faire
parce que les pauvres pendant un mois il
pas travailler mais mais c'est pas la
solution non je pense que en tout cas le
le constat il est partagé et de ce point
de vue là il y a des similitudes entre
la crise de la pêche et deagriculture
c'est que il me semble qu'aujourd'hui
c'est le point d'équilibre il y a une
transition qui est en cours de nos
pratiques sur l'impact environnemental
et je crois que sur la la question des
des CAC en particulier sur la pêche C
évoqué et la question c'est comment
est-ce qu'on accompagne cette transition
comment est-ce que l'on fait en sorte à
la fois que le pêcheur comme
l'agriculteur soit reconnu dans le
travail qu'il fait euh qu'il ait un
revenu qui soit un revenu décent mais
c'est vrai que de d'ouvrir des
financements juste pour ouvrir des
financements ça n'a pas trop de sens et
je crois que de ce point de vue-là on a
un vrai défi à ne pas opposer j'allais
dire l'activité humaine et la protection
de l'environnement c'est c'est c'est un
défi auquel on ne sait pas totalement
répondre aujourd'hui et pour lequel on
n' pas rassuré nos concitoyens et au
premiers chef desquels les pêcheurs les
agriculteurs vous avez entendu François
Xavier bami qui est la tête de liste LR
pour les européennes sur place qui
parlait de la souveraineté alimentaire
Alain cadeek Le rappelé 70 % du poisson
consommé aujourd'hui dans notre pays est
importé François Xavier bami dit il faut
faire de la pêche une filière
stratégique au même titre que
l'agriculture notamment sur cette
question souveraineté vous le suivez
là-dessus écoutez moi c'est toujours la
même chose je veux bien suivre si on est
certain que la ressource est présente le
problème aujourd'hui c'est quel est
l'état de la ressource et je crois aussi
que les pêcheurs même s'ils ont amélioré
c'est incontestable leur leur capacité
en tout cas de de de de de récupérer des
des quantités importantes comme les
agriculteurs et bien s'inquiète aussi de
la ressource et donc c'est là qu'il y a
un difficulté si effectivement on amène
des contraintes en France pour
l'agriculture comme pour la pêche mais
que parallèlement on est dans un système
concurrentiel où il est plus facile
d'importer des produits venus d'ailleurs
forcément ça crée un déséquilibre mais
en même temps il y a la question de la
ressource et cette questionl elle est
pas tout à fait tranchée elle est pas
tout à fait claire j'évoqué excuse-moi
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure les les les
règles mises en place par la politique
commun de la pêche il y a une règle
importante qui a été mise il y AEL mise
en place il y a quelques années à
l'époque j'étais président de la
commission de la pêche d'ailleurs euh
c'est ce qu'on appelle le RMD le
rendement maximum durable qui qui est
mis en place aujourd'hui 60 pratiquement
70 % des espèces atteignent ce RMD le
RMD ça veut dire quoi je prends
rapidement une une métaphore bancaire
euh vous avez une somme d'argent que
vous placez qui vous rapporte tant de de
pourcent tous les ans et bien le
principe du RMD c'est pareil si vous
avez une biomasse de poisson qui génère
tant de de de de de de juvénil et bien
nous ne pêcherons que et c'est ça le RMD
c'est c'est l'Europe qui l'a mise en
place heureusement qu'on avait l'Europe
pour le mettre en place c'est pour ça
que l'Europe est importante ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui les pêcheurs sont
parfaitement conscients qu'ils ont
besoin de préserver la ressources pas de
poisson pas de pêcheurs donc ils le
savent mais ils sont suffisamment
soutenus ces pêcheurs aujourd'hui pas du
tout justement on je vous disais tout à
l'heure le plan de sortie de flotte un
certain nombre de de de décisions
gouvernementales ou européennes parfois
viennent à l'encontre de ce ce cette
activité qui est extrêmement qui est
nécessaire aussi pas seulement en terme
de PIB c'est pas énorme en terme de PIB
mais en terme d'aménagement du
territoire nos littorau s'il y avait
plus de pêcheur ce serait dramatique
vous enferez un thème de campagne
européenne vous ah oui absolument oui
oui bien sûr je je suis au côté de
François bami je pouvais pas être là
parce que malheureusement j'avais
quelques soucis de santé mais j'aurais
été avec François Xavier et Bruno
normalement en vend la gauche est pas un
peu absente sur ce sujet M non je crois
pas c'est c'est c'est des sujets des
préoccupations je crois que l'angle
effectivement est s différent entre ce
que la vision qui est celle de de
François Xavier belle amie et peut-être
celle que qui serait portée par rapel
gluxman mais la question effectivement
de l'indépendance alimentaire que de la
ressource et du lien qu'il y a avec la
ressource c'est une question qui nous
préoccupe aussi avec des mesures
d'accompagnement que nous souhaitons
aussi que nous portons je crois que
Christophe Clergeot qui est député
européen é aussi engagé sur ce sujetsl
il a beaucoup euh il s'est beaucoup en
tout cas engagé sur les questions liées
à l'agriculture donc on sera présent
avec je crois l'occasion pour le coup de
montrer aussi une différence d'approche
entre entre la gauche et la droite alors
justement je voulais peutt faire une
petite remarque pardonne-moi mais ayant
présidé de la commission de la pêche au
Parlement européen la différence entre
les les collègues socialistes et les
collègues républicains et s'agissant de
la pêche j'entends bien elle est
infinitésimale par contre les groupes
écolo ou d'extrême gauche ont une autre
vision de de l'êche la campagne nous le
dira ou oui tout à fait tu as raison
mais plus largement sur la la crise
agricole alors la souveraineté
alimentaire dont on vient de parler
était quand même au cœur des des
réponses de Gabriel hatal notamment il
veut inscrire cette souveraineté
alimentaire dans la loi est-ce que les
réponses ont été à la hauteur pour vous
non je crois que aujourd'hui clairement
on il y a pas de on n'est pas satisfait
satisfait de de ces propositions qui été
faites je crois que franchement la
question de la la crise telle qu'on la
vit aujourd'hui cette crise agricole
elle nous interpelle parce qu'elle est
d'abord multiforme on observe que
partout en Europe tous les pays sont
engagés mais pour des raisons
différentes en Pologne c'est la crainte
de la concurrence avec l'Ukraine euh
dans les pays je pense à l'Espagne et au
Portugal c'est pass face à la à la
ressource et à la sécheresse chez nous
en France on parle beaucoup de la
question des normes effectivement et euh
et de la concurrence hein qui qui peut y
avoir euh donc je crois queelle elle est
multiforme et c'est difficile d'avoir
une approche qui soit en tout cas une
approche identique à tous les pays c'est
aussi ce qui illustre peut-être euh
cette ce ce débat et les propositions
qui ont été faites et je crois que c'est
aussi un vrai débat de société ce qui me
semble intéressant dans cette crise
agricole que l'on vit c'est que en
quelque sorte on sent qu'il y a un monde
qui est en train de changer qu'il y a
une transition qui est en qui est lancée
et le monde agricole est peut-être le
premier qui fait face sans y trouver
totalement satisfaction et et avec les
inquiétudes qui qui qui sont les siennes
mais dire aujourd'hui simplement que
l'on
réduit en tout cas les les contraintes
liées à l'utilisation des produits
pesticides que l'on met des moyens
financiers supplémentaire je crois que
ça ne règle pas le sujet sur le fond et
d'ailleurs on voyait bien la cacophonie
au cours de ce weekend d'abord on nous a
dit sur écophyo et on arrête écophyo et
quelques jours après le ministre Béchu
disait non onarrête pas on va reformater
les choses donc je crois qu'il y a un
espèce deuse on les indicates donc moi
je suis assez assez sceptique parce que
je sais comment que ça se passe dans ces
cas-là et on a déjà vécu par le passé on
gagne on essaie de gagner du temps mais
dans la durée effectivement les sujets
seront repris et je suis inquiet parce
que si N règle pas le problème sur le
fond et si l'on fait encore une fois
comme ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure du
en même temps et qu'on ouvre juste le
quoi qu'il en coûte bah forcément ça
sera pas une réponse adaptée à cette
situation Mad cègue je suis désolé mais
je partage dire mon mon collègue
socialiste cela étant euh c'est vrai que
la France est quand même la je dire au
moins la championne d'Europe de la
surtransposition donc ça personne le
conteste aujourd'hui donc c'est c'est un
un gros problème vous allez peutêtre non
on va on va en parler justement de de
cette question puisque on l'a entendu
déjà dans la bouche de pêer V1 et puis
effectivement ça fait partie des
parilleur parilleur l'Union européenne
elle-même est également génératrice de
de de de normes toutes les tous les ans
il y a des nouvelles normes alors
évidemment qu'il faut des normes mais
aujourd'hui un agriculteur il y a il y a
10 15 ans il remplissait de pages
c'était bon aujourd'hui il lui faut 150
pages avant de commencer à produire
alors évidemment on va faire on va faire
le point parce qu'on va nous rejoindre
dans ce débat Christophe et h Duval
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
vous êtes conseiller d'État spécialiste
de l'inflation normative Christophe
Duval est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il y a trop
de normes dans notre pays et surtout des
normes mal ficelé
bonjourect
mesames je
précise de
chercheur c'est une questionès comple et
qui commence petit à petit mieux
con parce que ça fait
4 je crois que
c'estésident en 95 con prononcé de loi
sur la loi voilà sauf que depuis euh on
n jamais exactement quantifié cette
inflation normative et on ne le sait
concrètement queis finalement
l'informatisation par légifance qui
permet désormais de compter de manière S
et certaine le volume des textes alors
j' reviendrai ouais monsieur juste
pardon pardon excusez-moi je suis obligé
de vous interrompre parce qu'on on a on
a un problème de son et on a vraiment du
mal à à à à comprendre ce que vous dites
on va essayer de régler tout ça et et je
reviens très vite vers vous on va régler
ce ce petit problème technique Alain
CADC est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il y a trop
de normes dans notre pays ah oui et bien
sûr qu'il y a trop de normes il y a trop
de normes je pense que les les les
agriculteurs il est nécessaire qu'il y
ait des normes il en faut faut faut des
règlesut faut de mais mais on on en a
beaucoup trop parce qu'on en a généré
pourquoi on en a généré parce qu'on a
créé une technostructure qui elle-même
se crée son son son son travail son
problème et aujourd'hui il y a il y a
des normes sur tout il y a desnmes surt
et et et et les et les les agriculteurs
sont n'en peuvent plus n'en peuvent plus
euh déjà qu'ils ont du mal à à
travailler déjà que leurs revenus sont
extrêmement euh euh diminués euh
aujourd'hui euh ils sont euh assaillis
par des contrôles des contrôles
constants euh et donc il n ils n'en
peuvent plus bien entendu mais encore
une fois c'est en France on est quand
même les les les les les les champions
je vous dis la surtrposition on va en
parler juste parce que Gabriel hatal
dans ses annonces en fin de semaine
dernière évidemment il a fait les
annonces sur cette simplification des
Nmes sur quoi il s'est engagé Marion
précisément alors effectivement en fait
dans le cahier de doléance des
agriculteurs en colère figurait vraiment
en haut de liste la réduction des normes
beaucoup dénoncent une overdose
normative en France qui nuirait à leur
compétitivité à titre d'exemple et c'est
assez parlant aujourd'hui un agriculteur
passe 9h par semaine à rempiris des
formulaires pour répondre aux
agriculteur alors dès le début de la
crise l'exécutif a mis sur la table 10
mesures de simplification immédiate on
va en découvrir quelques-unes tout
d'abord cet allègement des
réglementations sur les ha agricoles une
seule réglementation contre 14 jusqu'à
présent la sortie également de
l'obligation de légale de
débroussaillement il faut ici souligner
la contradiction de certaines
injonctions et les agriculteurs étaient
obligés de débroussailler pour éviter
les incendies mais il risquent une
amende en cas de débroussaillage pour
destruction de l'habitat autrees mesure
en cas de projet agricole le délaai de
recours et raccourci de quatre à 2 mois
et puis il y a également effectivement
la suspension du plan écofyo qui a été
évoqué pour discuter là aussi des
mesures de simplification voilà pour les
premières mesures d'urgence mais
d'autres doivent suivre notamment la
simplification sur le droit du travail
avec par exemple des dérogation de la
durée légale du travail facilité pendant
les périodes de moisson et en plus de
ces mesures on est dans le mois de la
simplification annoncé le 26 janvier
dernier par par le Premier ministre oui
et en ce moment dans chaque département
les préfets et les représentants des
agric culteur travaille à regarder norme
après norme ce qui peut-être simplifié
c'était le cas le 31 janvier dernier à
Toulon Var Matin titit d'ailleurs vers
un début de simplification de
l'agriculture varoise plusieurs groupes
de travail ont été constitués et la
simplification est vraiment au cœur des
échanges un exemple des demandes locales
la réduction des démarches pour les
demandes d'aide à la protection contre
la prédation du loup voilà pour les
simplifications qui sont en train d'être
menées en France reste à savoir ce qu'il
sera fait au niveau européen puisque
près de la moitié des normes sont
européennes on sait que Bruxelles a
commencé à lâcher du l'est en proposant
de mettre fin à l'obligation de 4 % de
terr en jacher pour l'année 2024 mais
les agriculteurs sont nombreux à
demander aussi une révision de la
politique agricole commune les aides de
la PAC dont il bénéficie s'accompagne de
contrôles de plus en plus nombreux et de
contraintes de plus en plus contexte
complexe je voulais également attirer
votre attention sur cette déclaration
hier la secrétaire générale de la conféd
tion paysane était auditionné au Sénat
Véronique marchessau estime que l'objet
de la colère des agriculteurs a été
détourné que la colère qui s'est
exprimée ce n'était pas contre les
normes mais d'abord sur le fait de
pouvoir vivre de son métier est-ce qui
effectivement à vos yeux on s'est trompé
de problématique je pense je pense je
suis assez je me retrouve assez dans ce
dans ce constat là je crois que la
problématique aujourd'hui elle est d'une
que les agriculteurs puissent continuer
à produire que deux ils puissent vivre
décemment et sentent mieux que par le
passé parce que c'est aussi l'ensemble
de la société qui qui qui en attend de
de cela et qu'il soit pas dans un
système concurrentiel où ils se sentent
finalement en décalage par rapport à ce
que l'on a ailleurs ce que je trouve
intéressant dans dans les exemples que
vous avez donné où on parle de inflation
normative et de simplification vous avez
pris deux exemples et je voudrais les
illustrer parce que par la preuve
peut-être ça montre aussi parfois les
les les les travers que l'on peut
retrouver vous avez parlé des ha tout à
l'heure je sais que c'est un sujet qui
est très très cher à à à l'incadec euh
quand on dit qu'on met des des des
normes supplémentaires pour les ha
pourquoi c'est parce que quand on
regarde entre les ha qui sont plantés
les matres linéir de ha qui sont plantés
aujourd'hui et C qui sont arrachés il y
a un sold négatif c'est-à-dire qu'on
arrache malgré tout encore aujourd'hui
en France plus de ha qu'on en plante et
donc je crois que les normes
malheureusement ell elles sont un pisalé
c'est un une forme de palliatif face à
une situation où on a dû contraindre
effectivement peut-être ces transitions
et quand on prend l'exemple de la
simplification vous avez dans la
simplification parler du loup qui est
aussi une des thématiqu pour laquelle il
y a une grosse attente et bien c'est
évidemment aussi son une question
environnementale qui est cette
simplification donc moi je pense que la
question aujourd'hui c'est comment
est-ce que on accompagne ce mondelà
agricole pour aller vers cette
transition il n'est pas acceptable il
n'est plus acceptable il est plus
tolérable aujourd'hui que le monde
agcole et bien passe plus de temps
derrière un ordinateur pour remplir
effectivement des formulaires ils sont
là les agriculteurs pour produire mais
ils sont aussi là pour vivre décemment
effectivement de cette production là et
puis un autre sujet derrière je pense
qu'on aura l'occasion d'en parler et qui
a aussi beaucoup été évoqué parce qu'on
est aussi sur le terrain auprès de de
nos élus qui sont souvent des élus
agriculteurs c'est aussi celui de la la
transmission hein et notamment de
l'acarparement des terres et on l'a
beaucoup entendu c'est un des sujets
c'est une des inquiétudes que l'on peut
avoir donc juste dire comme un mantra il
y a trop de normes je crois que c'est un
peu simpliste un peu simplificateur moi
je crois qu'il faut aller sur le
vraiment sur le fond de cette crise et
les raisons de cette crise alors la
Confédération paysane on sait on connaît
son son son son positionnement il est il
est il est clair par rapport à la FNSEA
et par rapport aux autres syndicats
agriol euh je partage en partie
d'ailleurs ce qu'elle a dit il il y a
pas que les normes certainement il y a
pas que les normes mais je je suis quand
même convaincu que les normes pénalise
de manière importante très importante
notre notre agriculture alors quand le
Premier ministre dit c'est parti c'est d
en même temps c'estàd que pendant
nombreuses années il faut rappeler quand
même que son son
parti présidé par à l'époque par
Monsieur séjourné au au au Parlement
européen à vootter tous les textes qui
vont dans le le sens de plus de plus de
plus de normes et et et de plus de
contraintes farm to fork ils l'ont voté
les républicains l'ont pas voté la
restauration de la nature on est pour la
restauration de la nature mais on n pas
voté le texte en entier tout ce qui est
Green Deal c'est pareil et qui qui
pénalise nos nos agriculteurs alors faut
faut assumer un peu un peu tous ces
choix et et et en plus quand il dit on
va imposer à notre administration de ne
plus contrôler certaines choses euh
l'Office français de la biodiversité a
dit tout de suite nous pas question on
continuera nous à contrôler donc voilà
je je je suis inquiet entre ce qu'on dit
et ce qu'onon fait je crois qu'on a
retrouvé Christophe Duval je sais pas si
si si vous nous entendez et si surtout
on va bien vous entendre
Christophe non non mais c'est nous
pardon pour pour ces problèmes de
connexion on parle évidemment beaucoup
de simplification des normes est-ce que
c'est si facile que ça de
simplifier alors je dirais à titre
anecdotique que vous savez si j'ai fait
une recherche sur LG France vous trouvez
37 lois quient l'intitulé de
simplification 66 ordonnances 165
décrets et 68 circulaires ce qui montre
que c'est pas d'IER que simplifier le
volume normatif voilà alors je souhaite
bonne ch évidemment au Premier ministre
gabrielan je j'observe d'ailleurs qu'en
vérité dans un discours de politique
générale le premier à avir appeler à
laication administrative était Jacques
Chirac en 1974 vous voyez que il y a des
antécédents et peut-être la pente est
difficile à à remonter pourquoi parce
qu'effectivement cette inflation
normative dont on parle on en parle
depuis 1995 c'est Chirac encore qui dans
son discours d'investiture au Congrès
avait dit trop de loi la loi mais on ne
savait pas en
réité sentiment était prouvé j' dire
presque scientifiquement ce maintenant
on le sait depuis que d'une part légif
France a numérisé le Journal Officiel
les textes sont en informatique et qu'un
algorithme a été mis au point par le
Secrétariat général du gouvernement à la
demande du Conseil d'État en 19
2018 très tardif à titre anecdotique une
pure anecdote je montre ici le code
rural de
1965 petit format voyz pas dans l'écran
faisait 700 pas
voil je montre le nouveau code rural
pêch maritime mieux dans l'écran voyez
évidment il a changé for il fait 3000
pages si je mets les deux côte à côte
vous voyez effectivement l'épaisseur
voilà une réité qui n'est pas j'allais
dire scientifique parce que ce n'est pas
par l'épaisseur des ces doit en réalité
se prononcer sauf que c'est quand même
un indiceidemment qui peut marquer les
entreprises parce que les agricur sont
d'abord des entreprises alors elles sont
pas assintes à toutes ces règles mais
comme entreprise elles doivent se mettre
en norme et nécessairement dans ces
codes qu'elles doivent les trouver sur
la question de la la surtransposition
Christophe juval je sais pas si si vous
avez entendu quand le sénateur kadc en
parlait est-ce que cette
surtransposition dont on parle beaucoup
quelle est sa réalité
concrète alors je crois que c'est une
réalité qui fait assez consensus mais
qui est difficile à chiffrer elle fait
consensus parce que je crois que c'est
le Parlement quime à l'occasion de la
loi confiance euh avait demandé titre de
d'un article 69 je crois de cette loi un
rapport au gouvernement sur la
surtransposition et finalement bah le
gouvernement a fait rapport au Parlement
et a reconnu un état des fait qui est
une tendance dire peut-être
franco-française pas forcément sur
certaines de manière franfançaise en
tout cas qui est assez caractérisé c'est
un un rapport dans lequel le
gouvernement d'ailleurs mis un peu la
responsabilité sur le dos du Parlement
en disant oui mais c'est aussi vous qui
participez à surtransposer donc voyez
qu'il renvoyé la balle sauf que c'est
asszité à mesurer parce que le droit
communautaire a comme caractéristique
d'être fangible et il est donc très
difficile de repérer dans les normes
nationales ce qui est le part jeis dire
de l'incorporation strict au au au au
droit plein plein droit de du
communautaire de ce éventuellement le
sur transposition mais c'est un fait
aujourd'hui assez peu discuté on a des
partenaires européens qui sont plus
prudent alors il y a aussi les
techniques italiennes ou qui sont de
transposer et de pas appliquer façon de
faire Christophe Duval merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous je on va je vais
citer pardon votre livre puisqu'il est
apparaître en mars prochain chez plomb
ça s'appelle pourquoi la France crève de
trop de loi vous viendrez peut-être nous
en parler merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
été avec nous un mot puisque on
Christophe Duval c'est assez parlant ce
qui nous a montré l'épaisseur du code
rural et pour terminer sur la question
de l'avenir vous en parliez est-ce que
cet excès de norme c'est un frein à la
transmission aujourd'hui pour les
agriculteurs bah écoutez d'abord je
trouve que ce qui est intéressant c'est
quand il dit sur transposition il y a un
consensus mais il y a difficulté à
chiffrer donc c'est c'est c'est parlant
parce que en effet quand on comparare
les codes on voit qu'ils ont pris de
l'enloi mais c'est sur le cas sur tous
les codes et c'est pas spécifique à des
à des norm européenne surtransposé dans
le droit français hein je crois que de
ce point de vue-là on doit aussi nous en
tant que parlementaire au Sénat à
l'Assemblée nationale s'interroger sur
les texte effectivement que l'on vote et
qui sont nombreux il faut quand même le
rappeler et avec à mon avis à mon avis à
mon avis d'ailleurs le défaut de ne pas
supprimer aussi des textes qui n'ont
plus qui n'ont plus leur utilité mais en
réalité oui bien sûr que ça que c'est
une difficulté supplémentaire parce que
je crois mais c'est une difficulté
supplémentaire pour qui veut
entreprendre c'est pas spécifique
d'ailleurs au monde agricole c'est je
crois que aujourd'hui malheureusement on
est effectivement dans système où les
contraintes où le monde a changé et où
les ces changements impliquent ou
supposent derrière des changements aussi
dans les pratiques qui sont les notes et
forcément c'est très compliqué pour
celui qui veut entreprendre et je crois
que de ce point de vue là quand on dit
il faut soutenir l'entreprise quelle
qu'elle soit et je crois que c'est une
bonne thématique il faut qu'on
s'interroge sur la façon dont on met en
place un mot de conclusion alin cada qui
nous reste 30 secondes euh bah tout
simplement c'est vrai qu'on a trop de
loi aujourd'hui en France mais j'ai cru
comprendre que le Président de la
République avait décidé de gouverner par
ordonnance dans les années qui dans les
mois qui viennent comme ça le Parlement
benah on en parle plus déjà qui voulait
plus du Parlement comme ça ce sera
encore mieux euh par rapport au monde
agricole je voudrais quand même rajouter
un un un petit un petit élément c'est
que les modèles agricoles sont
différents entre la France l'Allemagne
l'Italie l'Espagne et ça aussi c'est à
prendre en compte mais ce que ce que je
veux dire pour terminer c'est que les
agriculteurs aujourd'hui je pense qu'on
est d'accord là-dessus ce qu'ils veulent
c'est vivre de leur métierou et
participer à la souveraineté alimentaire
de notre pays vous quand on réfléchit on
se rend compte que à partir
d'aujourd'hui on est en déficit
aujourd'hui alimentaire aujourd'hui la
la France importe plus nous reste 2
secondes un dernier mot alin écoutez je
souhaite simplement mais j'ai du mal à y
croire que toutes les promesses qui ont
été faites par le Premier ministre soit
tenu voilà on suivra évidemment tout ça
avec vous vous restez avec nous regarde
ce qu' de nos quotidiens
[Musique]
régionaux et Marion on commence par une
personnalité politique à la une de nos
journaux oui la crise baayrou titre le
télégram en affichant le visage du
patron du MoDem qui a donc annoncé hier
soir qu'il n'entrerait pas au
gouvernement suite je cite un désaccord
profond comme l'évoque également la
Dépêche du Midi François Baayou qui
explique avoir refusé le ministère des
armées mais qui brigait celui de
l'éducation nationale mais faute
d'accord sur la méthode et la politique
à suivre l'avenir ministériel du
président du model s'arrête donc là à
noter que ce dernier ne cache plus ses
doutes sur l'expérience du nouveau
Premier ministre et sur la composition
du gouvernement très orienté à droite et
le Premier ministre qui est attendu dans
les haut de France Gabriel hatal doit se
rendre à blandec dans le Pas de Calais
aujourd'hui une commune qui a été
particulièrement touché par les
inondations de début janvier et où le
Premier ministre s'était rendu au
lendemain de sa nomination le Pas de
Calais qui est de nouveau en vigilance
crue à chaque alerte on a peur révèle
les habitants au journal La voie du Nord
médecin étranger il y a urgence c'est la
Une de cor ce matin des praticiens
syriens vénézuéliens ou encore allemands
qui se sont confiés au journal et qui
racontent leur parcours du combattant
pour faire reconnaître leur savoir-faire
mais aussi la précarité professionnelle
qu'ils subissent l'État veut changer les
choses et il faut aller vite selon
notamment le président de l'ordre
régional des médecins cors qui s'exprime
dans le journal très rapidement on parle
Coupe de France on parle du puit oui ils
ont été invincible titre l'éveil de la
Haute Loire pour saluer effectivement la
victoire de ce petit Pousset du pu foot
club de National 2 face à l'aval club de
Ligue 2 merci Marion merci àad merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous merci
michber merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve demain très bonne
journée